lake is now just 37 percent full this
week it could hit
its lowest point ever 8 news now
reporter sally jaramillo joining us in
studio with what is being done to change
the problem
brian right now we're about to break a
record the lowest level the lake has
been at
since it filled in 1930s was in 2016.
in the next couple of days we're going
to be at that again
if we have a federal shortage in 2022
that would be a decline
of about 8 000 acre feet of water to
nevada
right now it would not cause any cuts
here because we don't take
all the amount we are allotted out of
the lake but to help save water governor
steve siselek signed a bill that gets
rid of
non-functional turf beth moore with the
southern nevada water authority says
that is grass that never gets stepped on
like in medians near sidewalks or
parking lots
we've identified that there are
approximately 5 000 acres of
non-functional turf in the valley
that accounts for about 12 percent of
our water use
mandatory cuts to how much water is used
would hit california and arizona harder
however because of complex agreements
with nevada
they would be using credits from
previous years to offset those cuts
that means they would still take large
amounts out of the lake
the biggest water users are not on the
strip it is
farmland the strip only uses about four
percent of our water
and ted and now ted it's been way too
long since we had rain
right may was the last measurable
rainfall you know that we were talking
about this may
mid may is the last time we actually had
one hundredth of an inch right
last time we've actually had a pretty
good amount up to three tenths of an
inch
that was in mid-march so it's been quite
some time we definitely need some rain
that's right ted and we usually see all
of that rain usually
the beginning of the year like february
march and even monsoon season and
last year it was a very dry monsoon i
don't even know if you could call it
monsoon season last season right because
yeah we just picked up a trace then too
yeah we certainly need some water
we know if it gets rained sally we
talked about this too it's really not
going to make a huge
dent in our a lake mead supply because
it really comes from the colorado river
like she was just talking about
however we can do if we can do anything
to save and conserve that water that's
great so if you want to check and see
what your watering schedule is during
the week go to our website
eightnewsnow.com and see what your
watering schedule is and do not turn on
those sprinklers on the hottest part of
the day that's between 11 o'clock
and 5 pm do it earlier in the morning so
we